What RIFE program could you use for Chrotic Nerve Syndrome?
So, Chrotic Nerve Syndrome is a type of neuropathy.
And so that's what I would think to use neuropathy.
I would also use inflammation.
The inflammation program may help more than anything.
I would also think of anti-inflammatory nutrients as well.
And I would look at if there's anything that you're doing dietary wise
that may be causing inflammation, like different foods that you might be eating
that you could have a sensitivity to that is causing inflammation.
That would be my go-to thing would be those things.
You could definitely run the neuropathy,
depending on where it is, but you could definitely run the neuropathy type programs as well.
That might help.
If you don't go to a chiropractor, think about going to a chiropractor to get things checked out.
Because it depends on what it's related to.
Whatever you're diagnosed with something that says syndrome,
it means that it's basically a collection of symptoms that may have multiple different causes.
So getting to a cause would be the thing to do.
So I don't think we've spoken.
The person who wrote this question, I don't think we've ever spoken about this.
So if you want to have a conversation about this,
and we can get into some more details about the history of this,
or you and possible causes, I'd gladly do that as well.
But you always, whatever you deal with anything,
you want to see if you can figure out what the cause of it is.